tratamento para GAP Lore tratamento
convencional não funcionou bem Eu tô
entendendo que o tratamento convencional
foi feito com antibióticos porque a
infecção do hilor que é uma condição
muito comum que afeta o estômago e pode
levar problemas como úlceras inflamação
de estômago que é a
gastrite geralmente é tratado com uma
combinação de antibióticos e
bloqueadores de ácido estomacal né os
famoso bloqueador de prótons para azóis
e geralmente quando funciona o médico
tenta uma outra combinação de
antibióticos Mas a gente pode pensar
aqui em outras abordagens mais naturais
antes de tudo é importante você
confirmar a presença da infecção do
hilor através de testes como o teste do
hálito ou exame de feses ou a biópsia
que pode ser realizada durante a
endoscopia se a infecção de fato for
confirmada o tratamento convencional não
foi eficaz você pode tanto mudar o
esquema de antibióticos Como pode também
o considerar outras opções naturais
então uma abordagem integrativa e
natural poderia ser o uso de suplementos
e alimentos com propriedades
antibacterianas e antiinflamatórias por
exemplo nós temos o extrato de semente
de erva doce também conhecido como
carvon antivas e semente de era doce ele
tem sido estudado por suas propriedades
antibacterianas contra cilore também
temos os probióticos com cepas de
lactobacilos e bif do bactério que pode
ajudar a restaurar o equilíbrio da flora
intestinal do microbioma reduzindo a
inflamação o própolis tem propriedades
interessantes anti pilor o zinco
carnosina também tem essa ação anti
pilor alimentos ricos em antioxidantes e
polifenóis é o caso do chá verde o suco
de mirtilo né da fruta vermelha e também
outras frutas vermelhas outras bervas em
geral São benéficos o áo também tem
propriedades antibacterianas pode ser
consumido em forma de suplemento ou
adicionado a sua alimentação aumentar a
quantidade de alho e mudanças estilo de
vida são sempre essenciais mantendo uma
dieta equilibrada rica em frutas
vegetais e grãos integrais e evitar
alimentos processados e ricos em açúcar
e gordura artificial que podem ajudar
então a reduzir a inflamação e melhorar
a saúde geral do estômago praticar
atividade física regular é muito
importante e gerenciar o estresse também
é essencial e sempre consulte o médico
que entenda dessa situação e o
nutricionista para uma avaliação
personalizada e para o ajuste de
tratamento de acordo com as suas
particularidades individuais